[Music]
is very impressive he's a 16 year old
medal winning skateboarder who on may
17th made x games history when he landed
the first 1080 in mega ramp competition
that is three full rotations in the air
never been done before take a look
[Music]
because he's going higher
[Music]
[Applause]
yesterday and i'm sure this is going to
change things in skateboard began
please welcome mitchy brusco
wow
uh so much to talk about first of all
mitchy that was three
revolutions in the air yeah four three
four three sixties three full 360s and
uh
is it possible to do more like what's
the next step can you do more can a
human being do more than what you just
did um
well people do more on snowboards so i
think it is possible those guys who
knows what they're on i'm talking about
um this is a skateboard i want to you
don't know if you want to go it's really
scary um that's scary kind of
but uh
i think
by the end of my career i think i could
possibly do more than that if i really
pursued it and if i really wanted to but
i think the progression of skateboarding
is in other areas than just spinning
like combining tricks with the 1080
would i think would be a little bit more
impressive than just spinning another
180. wait a minute so you're saying that
you would do a 1080 but be making a
waffle while you're doing it
ordering a pizza
i mean i mean i can't imagine doing i
couldn't imagine you doing that and then
i see you do that and now you're saying
now let's ramp it up and we'll add
things i'll put on a sports jacket
and paint on a mustache as i'm doing the
1080. that blows my mind how do you i
mean how do you even prepare for how do
you prepare to do that you must fail
many times before you get it right i
mean as you can see i'm wearing a lot of
pads when i do have knee pads elbow pads
and a helmet on and
what you can't see is actually have butt
pads which are actually shorts with pads
sewn into them i have a rib protector
even a little bit of shoulder pads just
in case it goes really wrong i wear
i wear butt pads for aesthetic reasons
on the show
i have no butt so it's uh but you don't
need to hear about that and you
shouldn't
um what i'm amazed is that you have
apparently
hey
watch it kid
you have a fear of heights which i can't
believe i actually do um it's not so
much on my skateboard it's
it's
when i'm standing up on the mega ramp uh
that that clip you saw how high is the
mega ramp it's about 90 feet tall the
highest point of it so i get i'm freaked
out when i'm up there i like looking
over the edge and stuff but when i'm on
my skateboard i know i'm gonna be fine
like i know i'm not gonna fall off the
ramp or i'm gonna make it over the gap
and i'm gonna be fine when i'm on my
skateboard but when i'm up there
and just like standing and was it
shaking a little bit it freaks me out
that's so funny that you're up 90 feet
in the air it frightens you but the
minute you get on the little board with
wheels
and prepare to fly through space you're
like now we're good
you are by the way we heard before the
show uh that one of your favorite
milkshakes uh is uh is peanut butter
yeah yeah i wanted you to have one
yeah i just want you to have one to keep
you
that's awesome uh you andy wanted one
too but he has a lot of kahlua in it
this actually was all kahlua